في صديق كشفت اللجنه الوطنيه للحج والعمره
والزياره للعربيه عن ارتفاع مؤشرات
الايواء والفنادق في مكه المكرمه خلال
الفتره الحاليه بسبب توافد اعداد كبيره من
المعتمرين من مختلف انحاء العالم مشيرتان
الى ان النسب التشغيل قد تصل الى 70% نظرا
للتزايد اعداد الزوار والمعتمرين واضافت
لجنه ان هناك نحو الف فندق واكثر من 250
الف غرفه فندقيه بمكه
بتصنيف يتوافق مع المواصفات العالميه
جاهزه لاستقبال المعتمرين لافته ايضا الى
وجود نحو 350 شركه ومؤسسه عمره تقدم
الخدمات للمعتمرين والزوار منذ وصولهم
وحتى مغادرتهم بعد اداء مناسك العمره
والزياره وكانت وزاره الخارجيه اطلقت خدمه
اصدار تاشيره المرور للزياره للقادمين جوا
الكترونيا التي بدورها تتيح واداء العمره
وزياره المسجد النبوي الشريف
انضم الينا من مكه المكرمه رئيس تنفيذي
لمنصه زمزم لخدمات المعتمرين في مجال
النقل
والفنادق عمر سراج اكبر سيد عمر مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه
يعني الان ارتاد الارتفاع في مؤشرات
الايواء والفنادق في مكه المكرمه ما هي
اسبابه كيف تختلف
المواطن الهواء والغرف الفندقيه عما كانت
عليه سابقا اذا كان هناك من طوارئ كبيره
يعني
طيب اهلا بكم وبكافه الساده المشاهدين
طبعا اليوم وزاره السياحه وضع الضوابط
جديده فيما يخص لوائح الايواء بشكل عام
ادت الى تاثير مباشر على رفع جوده الخدمه
سواء كانت حول المنشاه او داخل المنشاه
وضع ضوابط عاليه في تصنيف المنشات
بالاضافه الى اللائحه التي صدرت مؤخرا
ويكون النفاذها بعد 50 يوم سيكون لها
تاثير مباشر باذن الله تعالى على تحسين
الجوده بشكل مباشر لضيوف الرحمن باذن الله
لكن بماذا تختلف اليوم
عفوا
ما المواصفات يعني التي تختلف بها اليوم
هذه الغرف واماكن الايواء عن سابقتها طبعا
في السابق كان هناك عندنا عاليتين للعمل
كان هناك في اليه اليه المساكن المخصصه
للحجاج والمعتمرين وكانت تحت اشراف لجنه
معينه والان الضوابط التي وضعت هي ضوابط
عالميه دوليه انترناشونال فيما يخص تصنيف
الفنادق وفيما يخص
يعني تقييمها من قبل اللجان المتخصصه من
وزاره السياحه مما ادى الى تحسن الجوده في
هذا المساكن
ما هي الاسباب هذا الارتفاع في هذه
المؤشرات في هذه الفتره تحديدا
طبعا المدينه المنوره طبعا تعزوا
الى اسباب من اهمها التغيير السياسه
التاشيرات الجهود التي بذلت مؤخرا من قبل
مقام وزاره الحج والعمره مقام وزاره
السياحه كان هناك جولات مؤخرا لمعالي وزير
اهل الحج والعمره لمختلف دول العالم كانت
اخرها لدوله الجزائر طبعا هذه كلها اسباب
ادت الى رفع الوعي عن سهوله الدخول اليوم
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه بالاضافه
الى التاشيره التي اجزت مؤخرا من قبل
الدوله فيما يخص المرور لمده اربع ايام
هذه كلها اسباب مجتمعه ادت الى وجود
تدفقات عاليه على منطقه على السعوديه بشكل
عمومي وعلى مكه والمدينه بوجه الخصوص من
المستوى التي تقدم به 350 شركه ومؤسسه
عمره اليوم الخدمات للمعتمرين والزوار
طبعا اليوم هناك تحسن ملموس وملحوظ بشكل
يومي في الخدمات المقدمه في ظل المتابعه
الحثة الموجوده من قبل وزاره الحج والعمره
وهي تشمل جميع مراحل الخدمات ابتداء من
استقبال المعتمرين في مطاراتهم بالاضافه
الى عمليات النقل بالاضافه الى عمليات
التسكين وحتى مغادرتهم سالمين غانمين وهم
يحملون ذكراد طيبه باذن الله تعالى الى
بلدانهم